you're watching gamespot at summer game
first i am tomorrow saying and i am
joined by matsumotsan and nakayamasan
from capcom uh one of the big games
obviously of the show is street fighter
6 playable on the show floor i've played
maybe three hours of it and i'm going to
ask the fox some question
so first things first i guess um coming
off street fighter 5
had a kind of tumultuous cycle and
eventually got to a really good point um
what were the key objectives going into
six and what was the kind of ethos
coming into a new game so one of the
things that he wants to really focus on
with street fighter 6 is the whole
element of communication obviously you
know as a one versus one fighting game
the communication that happens between
uh
the fighting opponents is very valuable
but
there's other elements with street
fighter 6 like the the new uh battle hub
mode that we just announced we want
there to be
provide to deliver an ex like a an
experience that allows people to
communicate with with people with uh
people all over the world and kind of uh
enhance that aspect of it
i guess my main kind of takeaway from it
is it's quite mechanically dense there's
a lot to think about um even more so
than uh street fighter 5 it feels
almost in terms of what i have to think
about closer to something like third
strike
what does it say about the game that
you're now willing to have all these
mechanics layer over each other it felt
like five was a little more like let's
pare it down a bit so more people can
play it are you now thinking
let's just do what we need to do to make
sure it feels like a kind of fighting
game of depth and just hope that the
hardcore crowd are happy yeah i mean
with street fighter 5 there were there
were aims kind of make it a little more
like uh easier to kind of get to uh dive
into but with street fighter 6 as well
um you know with like the new drive
system they wanted to
provide new moves that are connected to
this system like maybe do like a drive
impact where you can execute by pressing
two buttons simultaneously
and
having providing all these different
layers within the same system they
wanted to give that kind of flexibility
back to uh both core and new users
i'm interested in kind of like the style
of the game the visual style and
aesthetic what is for me it felt like
it's it's really earning the name street
fighter
it feels a little more like gritty and
on the road whereas five felt a bit more
like
like a spectacle esports event um what
was the kind of thinking going into the
visual style and the audio style and the
kind of fidelity of presentation also
kind of like what was the objective with
it yeah so i mean uh as you mentioned
with with the stream being in the actual
name of the game uh there definitely is
that uh that art direction that we're
going for and this is kind of like a
take back to you know back to like the
street fighter one days when we had like
the graffiti on like the the brick wall
that breaks through and then also you
know street fighter iii had it also had
a very strong uh street hip-hop urban
culture sense in terms of the aesthetics
and um but i mean not only that you know
we want to
you know present to present the game in
a way that that modern game players will
kind of
uh
will be able to resonate with so there's
definitely multiple branches that were
taking into consideration and and that
art style just seemed was a perfect
match for street fighter 6.
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
true
jamie wins
can you talk about um
what was the kind of thinking with the
adventure style mode that is that has
been announced which is really cool
where you're moving around the city and
that kind of stuff and also how
expansive is that should people
expect to play it for like 10 15 20
hours is that something that you expect
people to come back to a lot and
yeah how much depth is there there yeah
so it's uh we can't really say about
like how many hours of gameplay this is
going to deliver but uh one of the
intentions of this mode uh that amazon
really wants to emphasize is that this
is
they've um with i mean with past street
fighter and in traditional fighting
games there
is usually only like a training or
tutorial mode and then after you
complete that it's like okay now just
jump it right into the actual fighting
game element of it and this is
one of the the objectives of this is to
kind of uh deliver a new and fun way
that a player a new player who might not
necessarily be as versed into fighting
games or might not be familiar with
street fighter to experience and through
that journey to be able to kind of learn
oh this is what this is what how you how
you play in the fighting game this is
what makes a fighting game actually fun
and through that journey then hopefully
they'll you know get more and more
familiar with the actual fighting game
aspect of it
and um you know i mentioned earlier
we're not gonna we don't have a lot of
information in terms of like how much
gameplay it is but we want to emphasize
the fact that this isn't just like a
supplementary bonus mode this is going
to be like a full like fleshed out mode
that we're putting a lot of effort into
into making and
and yeah it's it's a big project and
challenge of its own so
we hope you're excited for it
with that in mind um the last game to
have a world tour mode was street
fighter zero three if i remember
correctly which um the world tour mode
part of it was an actual world tour and
so far we've only seen metro city are we
going outside of metro city and also
will it have the kind of rpg style
system that um the zero three version of
it had that's funny that you touched on
the street fighter zero or alpha three
um that that is something that they they
had in mind and you know it's
they're definitely like acknowledging
that that mode in the past games uh
we'll have more to share with you down
the line so we hope you stay uh stay
excited
uh last question i asked twitter what
they wanted to know most about the game
and a lot of people were asking why does
ken look so sad
um do you have an explanation for why
ken looks so sad is he still is he still
married is he divorced now what's going
on we haven't officially announced that
particular character so there's not a
lot that we can say about it but you
know story is a very uh important aspect
for for characters in in general
and um
uh we don't like to see a lot of people
like you know
dying
in these in these games but um
we uh we hope to be able to share with
you some more information down below
thank you so much for your time so there
you have it for street fighter 6 we've
got plenty of gameplay on gamespot.com
and youtube.com
gamespot and keep it locked on the site
for the rest of summer game fest and
more coverage around street fighter 6.
see you later everyone
[Music]
foreign